welcome to this site event on
infrastructure
i'm co-hosting with us president joe
biden thanks for your engagement joe
the g7 has set itself the ambition of
making the world a better offer on
infrastructure investment
today we are relaunching our joint work
as a partnership for global
infrastructure and
investment with our joint d7
infrastructure initiative we are
building on strong national and regional
initiatives such as the eu global
gateway initiative and similar
initiatives of other g7 members
yet another example of our unity
and close cooperation at sg7
the decision to work together on this
offer to the world was taken last year
in carbus bay
since then we have worked hard and made
great progress
we have built a g7 structure for our
cooperation and launched concrete
partnerships on climate and health
on the structure of our cooperation
we are bringing together our development
finance institutions coordinate with
multilateral banks and private sector
and setting up partnerships and country
platforms
this is steep change for our cooperation
that we have committed to
we are boosting local vaccine production
in africa
germany has contributed 530 million euro
as part of a larger team europe and g7
initiative
we are building strong partnerships to
support the global transition to net
zero
with our just energy transition
partnerships we support an accelerated
clean and just transition of developing
and emerging countries towards climate
neutrality
the first
gtp was launched with south africa at
cops 26
i'm happy to announce today that the
germany why its development bank is
ready to offer a promotional loan of 300
million euro for energy policy reforms
as concrete support for this
gtp
this is part of germany's contribution
to collective g7 support of 8.5 billion
us dollar over the next three to five
years
but we won't stop there
in a joint effort with g7 partners we
are currently working towards additional
gtps within indonesia india senegal and
vietnam
the public sector alone will not be able
to close the huge investment gap we
faced in many parts of the world
this is why we are promoting innovative
instruments such as the emerging markets
climate action fund
in order to mobilize private investment
to for sustainable infrastructure
the g7 is committed to support
the emerging markets climate action fund
and germany is contributing additional
30 million euro adding to 25 million
euro we have provided last year
the fund can mobilize up to 50 euro
private capital for every single euro
public money we provide
with our total contribution of 55
million euro we can mobilize up to
2.75 billion euro
just back like our broader g7 again
there our work on promoting
infrastructure globally is also affected
by the current geopolitical situation
we have therefore discussed how our
investment globally in climate neutral
and low carbon energy including gas can
help us
as a temporary response to russia's use
of energy as a weapon
given the progress we have achieved time
is ripe to showcase our offer to the
world under a common roof i am convinced
the g7 makes a stronger better and more
convincing offer to partners globally
but beyond steps we have been taken
this is a long-term undertaking
germany will move this work forward
beyond the emma summit to make progress
towards an equitable world
and i will hand over
an even stronger joint initiative to
fumio end of this year
and now
i would like to
hand over to the united states president
thank you very much
well good afternoon
folks
our nations and our world stand at a
genuine inflection point in history
technology has made our world smaller
more immediate and more connected
it's opened up incredible opportunities
but also accelerated challenges that
impact on all of us
managing global energy needs taking on
the climate crisis
dealing with the spread of diseases
and the choices we make now
in my view are going to set a direction
of our world for several generations to
come
these challenges are hard for all of us
even nations with resources of the g7
but developing countries often lack the
essential infrastructure to help
navigate global shocks like a pandemic
so they feel the impacts more acutely
and they have a harder time recovering
in our deeply connected world
that's not just a humanitarian concern
it's an economic and a security concern
for all of us
that's why
one year ago when this group of leaders
met at cornwall
we made a commitment
the democratic nations of the g7
would step up
step up and provide financing for
quality
high standard sustainable infrastructure
in developing and middle-income
countries
what we're doing is fundamentally
different
because it's grounded on our shared
values of all those representing the
countries and organizations behind me
it's built using the global best
practices
transparency
partnership
protections for labor and the
environment
we're offering better options for
countries and for people around the
world
to invest in critical infrastructure
that improves their lives
their lives all of our lives and
delivers
real gains
for all of our people
not just the g7 all of our people
today we officially launched the
partnership for global infrastructure
and investment
we collectively have dozens of projects
already underway around the globe and
i'm proud to announce the united states
will mobilize 200 billion dollars in
public and private
capital over the next five years for
that partnership
we're here today because we're making
this commitment together as a g7
in coordination with one another to
maximize the impact of our work
collectively we aim to mobilize nearly
600 billion dollars from the g7 by 2027.
these strategic investments are areas of
critical
to sustainable development and to our
shared global stability
health
and health security
digital
connectivity gender equality and equity
climate and energy security
let me give you some examples of the
kinds of projects that are underway in
each of these areas
first
health
two years ago covert 19
didn't need any reminders
about how critical investments health
care systems were
and health sector and health security is
both to fight the pandemic
and to prepare for the next one because
it will not be the last pandemic we
under we we have to deal with
that's why the united states together
with g7 partners in the world bank
are investing in a new industrial scale
vaccine manufacturing facility in
senegal
when complete will have the potential
produce hundreds of millions of doses of
vaccine annually
for cover 19 and other diseases
it's an investment that will enhance
global vaccine supplies as well as
improve access and equity for developing
countries
second
the digital area
our economy's future increasingly
depends on people's ability to connect
to secure information
and communications technologies
we need to strengthen the use of trusted
technologies so that our online
information cannot be used by autocrats
to consolidate their power
or
repress their people
that's why the digital invest program
is mobilizing 335 million dollars in
private capital
to supply secure network equipment in
africa
asia and latin america
and the u.s government also supported
the successful bid
by an american company subcom
for a 600 million dollar contract
to build a global
subsidy telecommunications cable this
cable will stretch from southeast asia
through the middle east
and the horn of africa to europe
this will be essential to meeting the
growing demand for reliable
security high-tech connectivity
in three key regions of the world
third gender
when women and girls have the ability
and the opportunity to
participate more fully in their
societies and economies we see positive
impacts not only in their communities
but around the border across the board
we have to increase those opportunities
though for women and girls to thrive
including practical steps to make child
care more accessible and affordable as
we continue the vital work to protect
and advance women's fundamental rights
the united states is committing 15
million dollars over five years to the
world bank global child care incentive
fund
this public-private partnership
supported by several g7 partners will
help countries build infrastructure that
makes it easier for women to participate
equally equally in the labor force
fourth
and very important climate and energy
we're seeing just how critical this is
every day
the entire world is feeling the impact
of russia's brutal
war in ukraine
and on our energy markets
we need worldwide effort to invest in
transformative clean energy projects to
ensure that critical infrastructure is
resilient
to changing climate
critical materials that are necessary
for our clean energy transition
including the production of batteries
need to be developed with high standards
for labor and environment
fast and reliable transportation
infrastructure including railroads and
ports
is essential to moving inputs for
refining and processing and expanding
access to clean energy technologies
for example
the us government just facilitated a new
partnership between two american firms
and the government of angola
to invest two billion dollars in
building the new solar projects in
angola
it's a partnership that will help angola
meet its climate goals and energy needs
while creating new markets
for american technologies and good jobs
in angola and i suspect throughout
africa
and in romania
the american company new scale power
will be the first of its kind small
modular reactor plan
this will help bring online zero
emission nuclear energy to europe faster
more cheaply and more efficiently
the us government is helping advance the
development of this groundbreaking
american technology which will
strengthen europe's energy security and
create thousands of jobs in romania
united states
these deals are just some of what's in
store
and we're ready we're ready to get to
work together all of us
to lead efforts to lead u.s efforts in
my case appointed i appointed almost
hochstein my special presidential
coordinator to deal with the rest of our
colleagues
i'll lead the u.s whole of government
approach to drive a coalition a
collaboration with the g7 and our
partners around the world including
private sector and multilateral
development banks
i want to be clear
this isn't aid or charity
it's an investment that will deliver
returns for everyone including the
american people and the people of all
our nations
it'll boost all of our economies
it's a chance for us to share our
positive vision
for the future and let communities
around the world
see themselves
and see for themselves the concrete
benefits of partnering with democracies
because when democracies
demonstrate what we can do all that we
have to offer i have no doubt that will
win the competition every time
thank you
now i invite president vanderline to the
podium
thank you very much joe mr president
thank you olaf bundeskanzler
we've just tried to overcome a global
pandemic and it shook the global economy
and then as the global economy was just
recovering
russia's vicious attack on ukraine
happened
driving prices up everywhere from food
to energy
and casting deep uncertainty especially
in the most fragile countries
these are very severe challenges
we will tackle them head on and this is
why g seven partners are gathered here
but this must not and it will not divert
us away from our affirmative agenda
to show the world that democracies when
they work together provide the single
best path to deliver results for our
people and people all over the world
on climate
on health security and on digital
innovation
and indeed last november at cop26
thank you again boris for the initiative
we announced our plans to step up
globally investments
in climate positive infrastructure
this was our response to the commitment
we made at carbus bay and i will never
forget
the start of this initiative at glasgow
together with you joe and you boris it
was the beginning of a success story
today the world needs these investments
more than ever
and that is what the partnership for
global infrastructure and investment is
all about
so now what should we do
we should work
side by side and this is the one and
only way to maximize the potential of
our investments
and to demonstrate the power of
development finance
when it reflects democratic values
that is transparency
inclusivity
and sustainability
when it embraces high standards for the
environment and for the workers
and when it mobilizes the private sector
that's what success looks like
on our side europe's response to the
world's investment gap is global gateway
it's going to be under the roof of the
global partnership for infrastructure
and investment it's the team europe
approach
and to the 200 billion eur dollars
dollars that have just been announced by
the president of the united states
team europe is mobilizing 300 billion
euros
till 2027 over the next seven years from
both public and private sources
300 billion euros
for sustainable
quality infrastructure
and also for health infrastructure
investments that are transparent and
that improve everyday lives and bring
real benefit for the communities on the
ground
global gateway is fully at work and
we're listening closely to the recipient
countries
so that we can better understand their
needs and deliver the biggest impact
we already have many great examples to
share some of them have already been
named the mrna vaccine manufacturing
plants for example
we just extended this successful program
to latin america too
but for example also the great green
wall a project for food security and
land restoration on the continent
or take the submarine fiber optic cable
ela
linking europe to latin america
the upcoming clean hydrogen project with
egypt namibia and chile
and for example constructing a port to
connect christmas island in the south
pacific to the rest of the world
these are projects in the right
direction to travel
they are designed and implemented in
full consultation and partnership with
the countries and population concerned
because that's our way to do business
so my point is we need to see more of
these projects get off the ground in
every corner of the the earth
and for this we really need
as democracies to pull our common weight
the european union and japan for example
are already doing that defumu as part of
our connectivity partnership
or south africa has been named where all
g7
are supporting the just energy
transition
and we will continue our work and do
more projects together we will optimize
our collective power
because it is up to us
to give a positive powerful investment
impulse to the world
to show our partners in the developing
world that they have a choice
and that we intend to step up in
solidarity to meet their development
needs
in doing so we'll show once again that
democracies are prepared and meet the
moment
therefore my dear friends let's continue
the good work thank you
so now i may ask
prime minister of japan kumar kishida to
take the floor
okay
hey
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
now i will ask the prime minister of
canada justin trudeau to take the floor
thank you everyone it's good to be here
with president biden chancellor schultz
and everyone participating in this event
today
a year ago at the g7 summit in the uk we
made the commitment to change our
approach to investment for
infrastructure with the goal of
strengthening our partnership with
others around the world
foreign
i was just at the commonwealth heads of
government meeting in rwanda with me
this week with prime minister boris
johnson where we had the opportunity to
talk about these challenges with many
african leaders and earlier this month
in los angeles i met with my co-chair of
the un secretary general's sustainable
development goals advocates group prime
minister mia motley of barbados
we focused on mobilizing all possible
resources government the private sector
multilateral development banks and
philanthropic
foundations since the g7 last year we've
made significant progress together
including commitments to support
countries and managing their own energy
transitions away from coal and other
fossil fuels
canada doubled its international climate
finance commitment to 5.3 billion
dollars over five years in large part to
support these efforts which include a
one billion dollar investment in the
accelerating coal transition program
of course
if we want to close the infrastructure
gap we have to find ways to incentivize
greater private sector investment
because no amount of public money can
single-handedly fix this issue that's
why at home organizations such as our
development finance institute findev
canada is helping build a blended
finance platform in partnership with key
institutional investors
we're doing this to lower the risks for
private sector partners and put their
capital to work to help solve today's
big problems
canada's private sector is already a
significant investor investor in global
infrastructure and we're going to help
them do even more of it
not
canada will continue supporting these
efforts through a common strategic
approach i look forward to continuing to
work with you all during this summit and
mostly over the years to come
now i asked the president of the
european council sean michelle to speak
to us
thank you dear chancellor olaf schultz
thank you dear friend of the united
states for designing this event
the eu fully supports the g7 partnership
on global infrastructure investment
and the reason is simple
we have always been a leader in
cooperating with developing countries 46
percent of global development 8 trumps
from the european union and everywhere
almost 70 billion euros go to fund more
peace more prosperity and more
development
the g7
is committed to value standards
transparency principles
and so is the eu
we focus
on smart clean and secure investments in
sustainable infrastructure in digital
climate energy or transport and we also
invest in the power and potential of
people
in their education and health
and in cutting-edge research
the eu is a project of peace and
prosperity encouraged in the rule of law
and multilateralism
we rally our partners around high
standards of human social and workers
rights and our g7 partnership wants to
drive forward infrastructure that's
sustainable inclusive resilient and high
quality
in emerging markets and in developing
countries
for instance with investments in
vaccines and medicine production notably
in african countries
multilateral development banks will play
a catalyst role in mobilizing private
capital along with our public support
the european union is moving forward
with our global j3 initiative
at our eu africa summit last february we
announced an africa europe investment
package of 150 billion euros
we are investing in many countries
projects
in africa
and with africa
the submarine geographical gateway table
and the local pharmaceuticals
cooperation are two good examples
in the pacific we are very engaged in
the field of sustainable creativity in
transport energy and technology
in conclusion we need values and
standards and that's why we are fully on
board
i believe i'm convinced that the g7 and
the eu are taking the right direction
for a more stable and forward-looking
partnership i thank you
the last that will speak here to us is
the prime minister of italy mario dargi
thank you all of just two words after
everything has been said
this group of countries
is being the largest
financier
in assistance to investment projects in
developing countries
we have to do more
and we also want to be this effort
widely acknowledged in partnerships
with the developing countries
multilateral development banks and
especially the world bank
will be mobilized even further together
with the private sector
again a wide effort of partnership with
developing countries has to be
undertaken
the areas
you've you've heard the many areas in
which these investment projects are
going to be undertaken but on two areas
i'm going to put more stress
one is energy
and the other one is health care
energy
it's quite clear that in the present
situation
we'll have short-term needs
that will require
large investments in gaza infrastructure
in developing countries and elsewhere
but we have to make sure that they can
be retroverted to
carry hydrogen
so that's a way to reconcile short-term
needs with long-term
climate
needs
and also
many developing countries and one
continent africa
is uh
exceptionally suited
for investments in renewables
and that's where i would expect all our
countries
to fund
and design
identify and design
many many investment projects in this
area
on vaccines again this group of
countries being the euro european union
and the united states has been by by far
the largest donor this group of
countries including canada and japan
by far the largest donors of vaccines
and we'll continue
many initiatives in this field but now
it's clear that more is needed namely to
enable african countries and other
countries to produce the vaccines in
their own on their own land so that the
vaccine could be readily available to
their people thank you
thank you to you all